Ron cool okay wouldn't live we're gonna
do this just make sure my audio is good
ten moth graphics yep
she needed her immunity
can you business
maybe I just want to do right
you found
you are actually making sure
this is our future think of all the
lives of the safe game sounds are a
little low okay let me pause it then
[Music]
yes a lot where's Ellen Oh
I told her they just ran some tests
I told her
and she believed you
otherwise
didn't say your otherwise
this is I feel like la is gonna look
like them six months
a new duty yeah it looks really good I
got the HDR going
nice lens flare Sun flare
I like the guitar music pretty moody
I can't wait for the dance dance
minigame guitar minigame
it's crazy to think like this games on
this last gen and we're already moving
into the next gen this looks pretty
amazing so far all right now let's kind
of have a Red Dead Redemption to feel to
it
thanks yeah I like the little bubble
circle - that's all you need to see of
me anyway anything more would be a
detriment to your eyes stop something
something something
oh yeah we're getting to the camp gate
east - does he just staying there I'll
go
sure
grabbing my backpack
okay say I'm doing differently
yeah I hear you bowed down I don't know
that's why I'm I'm waiting to see myself
what what it's about you know what I
mean I don't always listen to the
reviews so telling I'm going to take
that light of the grave
why is my bubble keep like filling my
bubbles hi yeah I don't know why if to
the right all right hold on I'll even
let me if I fix it it's cause weird I
don't know I jumped it up let's see was
having in she's writing in her journal
yeah here's my Bob Ross shirt happy
mistakes
gave me a heart attack
hip-hip
this girl from China yeah about a clock
okay boomer right the audios look for
the game [ __ ] man I don't know why the
audio is low I mean I have it turned up
in my headset
a pika you want to look up maybe why the
audio would be low alright he's gonna
play his guitar song if it's low audio
pika I'm not gonna be able to hear it
it's bottles leaking oh [ __ ] I really do
have to do some [ __ ] guitar game and
swipe
[Music]
yeah there we go
sometimes yes I know that Mexico song
biscuit material that was dogs set to
television audio yeah but then I won't
hear from head so I won't hear it in the
head so will I maybe I could do both
right let me finish this awesome song
that's putting me to sleep okay hold on
hold on hold on let me try this guys
have any better when the audios now's a
little quiet for me with the voice I
don't know okay okay okay I hate why did
the chicken cross the road get hit by a
truck
seven eight nine it's a dad joke
are we gonna get to the stabbing yet or
we're just gonna listen to a lot of this
jargon I like that I like that bass that
continues on chopped oh so that was
right after the first part okay
she gives me you go crazy Arthur Azuka
Asian cowboy that's what I do every
morning just kidding
I always smell fresh what am I doing
here
and my jacket thoughts like that poster
just says thoughts
I'd take my journal there's a science
what's there these posters that's 20
about good good good what does it say
about something about good bye talk
about good bye okay Savage starlight
alright there's a lot of fan of that
font their blazing bliss the sound of
ecstasy alright let's get the [ __ ] out
of here oh wait there's my knife can't
go down my trusty knife
I think it's Szechuan places
let me see if I got this
which trigger said to call you
what happened I want to see the night
man where's Maria there's a quaint
quaint little town here
you
not
I like how he stops when I stop and then
he's like waiting for me see that's
really nice just those little touches
that's nice
all he's got a pet the dogs man
I always got a pit two dogs
in Spanish Harlem
tipsy bison that's funny we have a
restaurant in LA called tipsy cow
all right I guess all the city folk or
did
I don't like you ladies kissing in a
kissing there is good old selfie
I think it is Seattle yeah still a lot
city folk there
tells me that you
how do you know he didn't put poison in
there
no you know maybe it changed up there
now
once your face her face actually I like
her animations that's cool alright let's
go let's go I know just looking at the
details looks pretty dope blabber
not really Dena's done at a bunch
oh look at the kid he's just learning
how to walk well I mean it's so like
Apocalypse you know everything changes
maybe it snows more Maria
she's not my girlfriend
for just brands who liked kiss it's like
our turn his friends where they hold
hands all the time
she does look a little like Sarah
Silverman's
snowball time BAM
oh how do I make ball yeah take a kid
take it yeah you guys didn't know this
is actually snowball simulator 2020 oh
you got me
no plus X where do I go where do I climb
over this oh there oh geez
they're decking me
I like this tutorial oh well I didn't I
grabbed stuff how are we gonna do this
for an hour all right I'm just gonna
chase this kid up here
if you were not a child of helping
she's gonna Pelt this kid over and over
again all right there we go
yeah here's the stepping and she - yeah
dogpile yep you sure did
all right well that was fun guys but
that was all I'm gonna play The Last of
Us - and yeah
thank you
it's get on the overseas
where's my camera keep moving whatever
I now Dean threw those snowballs well
look who decided the joints
don't know why the camera keeps moving
whatever
for real pika
it go yeah yeah dude I mean you would
have had to think they'd done this like
a hundred times so when he just say just
be careful out there
you know what I mean like see you later
I gotta go find the clickers and the
clackers doomed in there doing all right
hold on I'm gonna fix the camera again
sorry guys sorry about that I don't know
why I keep shifting that's weird because
my windows open on the light slightly
shifting behind me I don't know Oh heard
about this lady
and they all got freckles
hmm yeah yeah Dylan you're supposed to
make dinner at your age get yourself
some ramen all I got like the nice cabin
right by the window freckle gang
I want to arm-wrestle this lady being a
gymnast
trust me it's in the closet
there's way
sure you don't want to do this when the
sun's out
his name is just man and her name is
just woman yes man yes woman
what are you doing wandering around out
here
Oh
you want to keep going
because he Manny's hometown
- where are we going you're gonna murder
me in the snow better be Santa and some
reindeers I'll tell you
you can do it I can do it
oh yeah what the hell happened I was
running there we go
and by the way it's more of a jog than a
run now let's see if her name changes to
a B yep and now he's Owen
well how would you even remember where
this is man well where the heck we are
you asked me to get back to that cabin I
would have no clue her hair looks really
good though her ponytail
holy crap it's a city
wait they've been in that cabin and they
didn't know that was around the corner
State burgers
see was in there
we can corner one of the drawers and get
confirmation
then we make them
yourself do you hear yourself
it's not just that should I sing King
garnets
you convinced great
don't
okay sounds good
[ __ ] it man I'm gonna go to that cool
outpost with the lights and [ __ ]
where the hell do I go here it's I gotta
go round this way
I gotta go up here and jump
come on run it whoo okay that sucked
oh my god cuz a run be slower dude I
mean I guess they are in snow but oh my
god dude alright that's it game over
I've tried oh my god this is the old on
I feel like I'm not angled correctly
very dark jeez that was a pain in the
rear
yeah and the snow dude one who would go
like this in the snow freakin freezing
well you get a hold to go prone okay I
got you
well Nell is usually a man's name so you
know getting them pregnant weird I'm
pretty sure cannot alive even before you
kicked them
okay alright go now pry it down this way
my camera keeps shifting uh okay I came
this way I have to jump over these rocks
I feel like I'm supposed to go this way
but it kind of ends right here oh I got
to do that shift through okay hold on
[ __ ] I don't know what's wrong with this
camera dude one second guys just stare
at just stare at that face for a second
well though the camera was I taped it
down to the tripod and the tape was
coming up so I just had to tape it back
down oh my God look at that
we should just chill with this forever
oh dude that looks like like art they're
a little slightly older art there oh no
I think it was a lady Arthur
I shoot him army how long melee yeah I
love the sound of his head getting
squashed oh [ __ ] I'm out of here okay I
guess I'm not out of there come on that
grabbed me yeah
wait there's another one what the [ __ ]
all right
clip healthkit old r2 to heal since his
coke versus a female coke you know okay
well how the [ __ ] dude I like wasn't
that started me crazy is like where am I
supposed to go here could I climb up
here no okay
feels like I got to go back up here but
I don't think I can climb up there
alright I climb up here no I guess I'm
going to go back down to that house I
guess and try to get on the roof I think
that's what I got to do wish it was like
a little bit of a marker to know where
I'm supposed to go I think I got to
sneak into this house though yeah that's
what they want
okay toggle flashlight
toggle flashlight I don't see nothing
what can I get here oh yeah just find a
clip yeah
all right that's cool
what's the can noise
try to see if there's anything else to
grab here I'll take that as a no I think
I got a exit to this door do I shoot
these boards no I don't think that works
I think I got to go down here yeah
I would just stay here oh I didn't mean
to shoot it again why did you shoot
again the hell alright see you later
zombie buddy I think if this was real
life I'm probably shot that guy just
stood there for a while we didn't like I
can't go out there was that lookout okay
down here
okay
hold our wand to listen and press
triangle yeah thank God she had Elevens
on there see anybody else uncheck this
bedroom real quick
yep see got more ammo oh how did you do
that what wait I'm just holding out why
does it shoot
dude that's tripped me out dude that
makes no sense
I thought L was to like zoom in but
obviously it's also to hold it down it
shoots like Jesus no that's a weird
mechanic dude unless my controllers just
busted I don't know what's going on
there do you that [ __ ] up her shoulder
I know do you know what did you want me
to do I didn't know like the dodge to
melee mechanics a little weird snap it
snap it
oh boy see how do I reload now she read
loads okay
or anything else okay I don't think I
hear anything else
I think it'll stop well you shouldn't
have gone on the woods by yourself it's
your fault um one of the hell am I
supposed to go now do we need to get in
the car maybe other bullet
you'll hold X reload I don't know
break it out later I feel like she
should be able to jump over something
okay oh [ __ ]
there's monsters everywhere what is our
home bear bear
that guy is trippin y'all I think he
took some of that angel dust snap his
neck snap his neck our to reload okay
good good looking out
it's not working eventful
oh man there's a lot of them brah
snap it stop it quickly
whoa what what hold on and that's not
[ __ ] yeah there we go
all right God that Dodge thing is a
little it's a little much there huh yeah
the graphics do look good it's good it's
good how you doing Daria it's a little
it's a little tough graphics do look
awesome
still trying to figure out where we're
going here okay can't get over that can
I get over this or oh god I gotta go
this way sure okay footsteps yeah it's
pretty dope though I mean it does look
really good
the dodging I guess I gotta get used to
the dodge and the fighting a little and
I got to get used to the gunplay
but yes still cutting back to Ellie and
Dena yeah I feel like this whole game is
gonna be kind of a downer it wasn't like
the first one was like super uplifting
but yeah I don't know
they said it's pretty dark I mean so far
it just feels dark and barely like
there's I'm in 30 minutes in or whatever
we're a little longer hour and
they will always be family but we were
just on a caught up one
we never talked about this stuff
that's a good question
to talk about
see ya later love horse I see this
course fun fact he told us something
like a patchy trivia there's Dylan
Dillons part Native American so knows
all about horses and that stuff he's
like the last limo Egan right Dylan how
do I get off this thing
it's automatic okay you know what's
interesting is like they're talking
about the PlayStation 5 does this like
smooth transition because of the SSD but
so far I've really not having many
loading screens here you know what I'm
saying so you kind of wonder if that's
really a necessity
ya know horses look nice I mean the hair
in this game I really like their hair
they did a good job with their hair it
feels good
you're blowing it let's see if we can
see ourselves in the mirror here we are
that's cool yeah you go ahead you move
that I'm just going to chill over here
come on Dina move your ass getting cold
out here
I used to be a radio tell what's in the
drawer it's a bullet you would think
people would keep their bullets closer
to them you know
oh just time laying around everywhere
and you know I'm some bees where we got
here in our book not infected for that
better
let's read it do you know Eugene all
clear
a little too clickers by the gas station
so this is like a journal of like what
they saw
well why would she not know what they
saw although oh I guess she did she just
didn't really I don't know she acted
like she's never been here before
imagine having hard leather on your back
what are you what are you talking about
Dylan this is a rated g chat just
kidding okay so can we can we stop
looking though horse saddle on blanket
what would you what would you ride a
horse with Dylan
are you coming or what are we going the
wrong way okay where are we going dude
there we go
Hinkel that way a barbed wire what did I
just load that I'm just closing it up
what's she doing but he did
you don't think Dylan they would have
got calloused over that time then the
horses might have let's go let's go
yeehaw you don't think they would have
gotten like calloused over time and used
to that on their back I mean I don't
know I'm not a rancher but I just
wondered
you're way too reckless
let me guess you're gonna kill me
yeah wasn't a good joke anyway
the sound of the audio is really nice
like the horse jump pretty good oh where
are we dismounting
she said check this out right I guess
this place
hanging out with you
yeah
I don't know
what am I supposed to go maybe this
camper want to check this camper I'll
blanket saddle Bible
I got a nut and bolt there's some bean
deeds
press this to view new skills these are
two teas listening movement speed okay
and oh I see
I need like a wobbling thought you was
crazy I feel scared a little anxious
just gotta keep it all go to the dance
don't [ __ ] up your friendship okay
not right now now with couvade all right
let's get out of here
you're not my horse here my horse
I don't know if I'm gonna play it all
the way through tonight I mean I'm gonna
die I mean I don't know how long it is I
think it's more than like a one-day game
maybe tonight maybe today and tomorrow
that's possible
there's blood everywhere that's a moose
the moose is loose
I took a while long ago oh wait I don't
want I forget this thing shoots like if
I hold l1 too long or something this way
Yeah right in the neck that's pretty
brutal
oh geez don't do that
oh yeah go this way
just gonna unlock it in case oh this is
just a bathroom what was the point of
that I guess just to get stuff ah what
are you doing dude
scary Dena peace I was not a good over
our to do it
by the way it's okay
yeah dude
I'll start picture
so Boston okay let's figure out how we
get out of here
got to go here I think the wait I don't
want that
[Music]
yeah Dena killer killer that's how we
roll pretty brutal it's my left to my
left
in the building okay
well I was just that one just that one
there's two of them
well why why did you do that why did she
shoot him on [ __ ] Sunday come on
quietly with the knife that was weird
dude
freakin better be so far run I'm diggin
it I mean I mean it's still kind of
tutorial phase and I'm still trying to
figure out like you know I think like
cuz I held down Al that's why she shot
him instead of stabbed him trying to
understand the mechanics just jealous
get out of your bottle okay so where do
we go now
what are we doing Deena I just want
circles for this truck am i helping you
yeah that's why I came over here in the
first place geez Deena get your [ __ ]
together here we go
so pika
[Music]
give me your hand
let's figure out how to get in there
well I know from the trailer reviews
that I think she's got to jump on this
thing
no maybe not I know it's gonna happen
there okay this is gonna be no bueno
Wow
thanks Dino I'm always clean is anything
in here I'm sooo it got here we got
bottles bottles just bottles okay
and the blood on the snow looks awesome
alright let's go in here I was feeling
we're gonna run into some some naughty
things Bend AIDS and whatever this is
what does it say man I was tired to go
what I did I'm gonna hurt you
me stabbing the air you know we're cool
okay - I guess we're not going this way
all right we got to go on top
right right okay I guess we got caught
up here stop here
then we gots to run and jump
we did it look at that first time I did
it on that one gotta go up here same as
you
what did he get some letter could give
is you scored by playing school what did
he get I'll show pic of Craig approves
same as you but what are you show me a
pic OH oh my monitor the internal
speakers are terrible I don't use the
internal speakers anyway I don't need
that crap it's over here
oh yeah I'm checking for supplies dude
it's the end of the world
gotta get whatever we can get man that'd
be like a no-brainer hey should we look
around yeah you should get this
flat-screen TV back to our place of us
got some good shows wife hurting how do
I know if I'm hurting okay press to view
okay there we go so now I just have to
are to X X X X okay all right so I need
to heal right now I don't think I need
to heal I guess they want me to okay
waldina all right I just from doing this
Tina better and not get me murdered I
wanted to shoot you either but you know
push comes to show oh oh wow look at the
spores spores look Dell dude and
lighting looks real nice real nice
let's get to the guys okay no I guess we
got to find a way through here
oh how are we gonna go do you know it's
like there's anywhere to get out of here
I guess this way through this hole huh
employee of the month being P's
meeting-place and marketing ploy of the
month once you get see the pictures a
little better but they're all people
that work in this naughty dog I'm gonna
keep it down can i hack this let's see
how this works
I think that's one
Oh
that's too
that's gonna work alright we'll figure
this out a second let's see if there's a
place to find info pry on this thing
Arielle to read combo is a date my good
boy got in play of the month
don't [ __ ] sell those or give them
away
feel better me not you know Kristen left
the real [ __ ] in the secret combos the
date my boy got employee of the month
[ __ ] who's his boy it's on the board
okay hold on we gotta go back to some
play in the month dang
2013
2013 that's the day could anybody read
the [ __ ] months on there okay July
well you know what it is it's gonna be
2013 right so I guess we'll just go
through the months that's just the only
way that makes sense to me
all right so we would have one
well July would be let's start with July
start from 7-7 2013 right 2013 booyah
first try how about that woo let's get
all this jazz that was kind of lucky yes
but you know I'll take it
okay
nothing in there I like that I'm like
trying to sneak around Dina doesn't do a
foot all right I feel like there's going
to be a dead body in here oh just peepee
sound No
[Applause]
okay wait a minute
Oh God are you kidding me
I wasn't quiet enough you know what I
mean
come on yeah yeah I know I'm not so
smart I just got lucky
no thanks
you don't want to you don't want to hang
out the clickers melody it's gonna give
melody nightmares I forgot about that
oh my god
okay I thought I'd click I guess I gotta
be even quieter I don't know I thought
it was just my still being too loud
[Applause]
yeah take that take that barnacle face
let's see what else are dying there's
that other monster no Tina stop stop
moving in my way
suck it that's it barnacle face take it
dang it
booyah alright stop
all right let's hit this [ __ ]
first
you know I hit the [ __ ] clickers
first dude cuz that [ __ ] clicker
[ __ ] me up man alright maybe you gotta
go like a long round Ondina this is what
the supermarkets looked at right after
the quarantine watches
[ __ ]
all right let's run No
okay I'm not gonna go off I don't know
what happened I'm guessing I died that
didn't go very well
okay let's try that again it's just like
God did I get it still showing our first
girl I'd killed I'm gonna go the long
way around all rights so save the pearl
at least it saved my first kill
one only first clicker to come over here
or I'm gonna go up to that clicker
I [ __ ] press Start go [ __ ] that
was [ __ ] [ __ ] deed I [ __ ]
press tell kill and then somehow she
still came around so I'm like what the
fudge man it's aggravating
do or do not there is no try yeah yeah
doesn't help me that Dena's like right
on my ass dude okay you're gonna help me
kill something Dena
[Applause]
gonna sleep go to sleep okay
let's go back this way now
there we go good night to you good night
good night good night Michael sighs
about Naughty Dog yeah maybe
all right there's this clicker in this
runner but I feel like I'll do a better
job if I get rid of the clicker it's
really good performance capture it off
turn around
oh why would I take my mask off oh
really play a whole long X oh what am i
doing
X guess I shouldn't use the malt out but
whatever
that's just dude okay hold on
let me just check the mark here all
right it's this we just had to kill 80
people man it was I don't know I keep
picking these up take that
all right I have a feeling we're gonna
exit here and it's gonna be no bueno all
right is that it so there's nothing on
this market shelfs that's really
depressing that's like what happened
during Cova dude the first week i went
to the market was like empty like this i
couldn't find nothing I think Colvard
was just a marketing ploy for The Last
of Us all right let's get the hell out
of here
let's go Dina I'm over this place hello
there we go
what's up page o ki dokie artichokie al
we're over here
I got the ropes how do I am rope well
yeah look yeah I feel the same way
go ahead you go first
ladies first
ha ha ha well if this thing breaks on me
dude that air duct doesn't look very
stable really like the sound design good
sound work hold l1
it's pretty winded oh I almost fell on
Deena Deena that was scary
well that was like half the shots from
the trailer so it's all new stuff from
here no I'm kidding there's a couple
more to enter the zoo
hard to turnips yes I page this game has
no turnips for you I wish it did
[Music]
we won't make it
where the hell's Deena Deena we're
supposed to go through this I think we
are
way to go Dina
feel like I'm going in circles
I don't know which way to go it's a
snowstorm oh I heard her something
why is Deena so much of a better light
at figuring out direction doesn't stop I
was like for a second I was gonna leave
the horse iron I'm like wait I made it
you can't leave the horses out here
freaking freezing there we go
good job with the door let's make sure
it's clear that there's some more
clickers and clackers and old
tallywackers this is pretty much I want
to move to the entire game this is it
right here this is me she's got to have
some amazing quadriceps you know what I
mean
her quads must be amazing
and their glutes
okay open this door
okay hell yeah that's how we do just
gonna take a little of everything for
real
Eugene Linden okay three one four I'll
flip area I couldn't get out of here
real dark that's not very good I mean at
this point who hasn't killed some
civilians you know I know that right in
my journal
sob hey giraffe oh yeah a little bad
draft was Yugi in touch with other
fireflies they hear about me and Joel no
he would have said something tonight was
crazy it feels girl alright we get it we
get it
nice job oh you're right cuz her mind
sort of the giraffe from the first game
okay I get it I get it I get a good
callback oh that's cool sold parts
I should just call Paikea and get some
new furniture you know what I'm saying
what do you guys think give me digging
it so far
Tommy and Eugene doll - all right put it
away
well so I'm just stealing everything you
you can go find the generator god I
can't read that read it
fireflies want to save the world
what are you doing over here Dean are
you gonna help me figure out what the
heck we're doing in this place where
it's in this back room let's check out
the straining card Laurent
foul clot foul cult real spark flip
brains are wrong something something
something Wayne's a Browns affiliation
born line brilliant numerous physical
elements he's like Professor X ok what
the heck are we doing here I lost the
thread oh I see a wire on the ground
I guess that's leading to a Jenny which
is probably going around here is there a
way to move this no maybe I gotta follow
the wire the other way huh maybe that
makes more sense a wire goes around
there and around here all the way over
to the rug around here there there what
the hell man where's this freakin thing
there it is oh my god
oh geez oh my god this is Jack kill me
all right there we go there we go there
we go all right that's trending you
might be right about that
let's go make some working stuff all
right
parts and supplies x4 upgrades fire rate
weaponry close I like this because this
is the thing that's been bugging me it's
got a lot of recoil okay so that I could
do right now oh it still says capacity
upgrades they do capacities okay I think
I already have capacity that was one of
my things when I got it all right what
about this gun nothing
oh six times scope that sounds dope okay
I think we're good there oh let's I
don't know that's just to use the table
okay
now I can't go there should I try
shooting that lock off you think I can
shoot the lock off
I guess the answer is no what are we
supposed to do that Deena ah there's
something I'm gonna need the floor it's
like a workshop how do we get there
what's your thoughts oh you're gonna
talk to me okay fine whatever Deena how
would we get underneath I feel like
that's there like I feel like I want to
make some I want to find like a tool
where I can like let's see is there
anything else on the tool bench I can do
other than guns and make like that the
clamp or something
that's weird okay what about here can I
do anything here scissors all right
okay listen speed oh okay I could just
start doing this listen motor movement
moved faster and listen mode increase
the speed of using a health kit okay so
the only one I can do here is this one
what a little was this one melee weapon
buying blame mainly weapon can I do this
yes faster crafting I mean I guess at
some point I'll need that then this one
yeah might as well do that
okay then the next one is increased
speed easing a health kit alright
alright alright
Journal you Jesus fire five pin day okay
rest of you oh I need all that stuff
okay I know how a melee weapon okay so
now what the heck I really want to go in
here but I can't shoot this lock is
there any way to open this door or do
anything no nothing nothing nothing and
it looks like there's something
underneath the floor here but how the
hell do we get through here Wow where
the hell did Deena go dude this is okay
ah she's kicking I was just kicking the
dirt off her pants thanks Tina
okay I'm nothing here
why are you standing here is there
something I'm missing here I can't talk
to her
what's up barrows how are you bro trying
to figure out what the heck I'm doing in
this place man it's driving me batty I
would jump through here went through
here and maybe we got to go back through
there ah
look look look look there we go
a lot of QuickTime events to tell you
it's a great question
six down
he was wall Jane it's a weed farm hell
yeah dude lick melody they found your
favorite place in the building I bet you
this is some dank stuff though dude look
at it's all drying out
still smokeable gonna be a little dry
the hell is that
okay what am i what am I looking for
here I bet this someone fetch a pretty
penny on the old farm here we go yeah I
used to have that I gave it to somebody
I might be joking I think I gave that to
my buddy Kenneth happy belated birthday
Kenneth he's so smart
he created a guest some masked ball
joints Oh live melody they're all points
dude you would not be dead are you
kidding me
with all those clickers and clackers out
there no way I'd be doing this in like
this place melody was it would be like
close to your home
now you're gonna smoke glass bro it's
not cool
smells did yeah it smells dank she's
just a dank oh she has the old Zippos
did the little leg trick I like it I
like it
and they're gonna put on some pink
floyd-- just trip out to the dark side
of the mood
I'd say it's number 25 drag it to vote
are we gonna actually see the kiss and
then we saw it on the trailer but I mean
shouldn't we like go back there and see
what happens
anybody what are you thinking by the way
we don't condone marijuana smoke
everybody for all those kids out there
unless you got a medical card it's all
have any story
i rated it too
yeah dude you gotta lick those lips
kissing time they better make really
good kissing noises
so wrong wonder what all cheese okay
that's not good
gotta go over here oh geez
I couldn't dodge god damn it where the
hell am I supposed to go just felt like
a nightmare
seemed like a really bad idea to go out
by yourself
[Applause]
okay
they all come from
it does is where we go
can we go out the back we can make a
break for the lodge what did you miss
bunch of kissing and smoking weed
Oh God do that pipe
updating the window that's her where you
see way up there
here use this
where do you want me to go oh now watch
me go that side all right all right
oh my god
okay so you can't you can't you can't
you can't kill her with a frickin
baseball bat alright damn it
[Applause]
come on goddamn it man
can you help me shoot the pluck the
clicker clicker clacker
frickin blacker Jesus clicker thing's
driving me nuts man
seconds hard to aim and mother all the
frickin chicken Oh where's that clicker
[Applause]
I'm dodging god dang it yeah give me
this goddamn pipe oh Jesus
let's go Jebus
how is ruff
that comes to us
I like I wish you I wish you could do
that
that's job
hey hey what's up Sean it's pretty cool
I'll get the door
there's no time for digging man it's
only time for riding
- whoa dude it's kind of x-rated Arthur
this is what it looks like when you're
in bed with the lady
I don't think she shaves her armpits
[Music]
Gillian Asian cock-blocker
melody
more like a what a vag blocker
yeah that's about right can't get rid of
all those guys let's get it all
this game is 25 hours gotta be a long a
lot of playthrough test the faint roar
yeah that'd be dope
just passing through ma'am that's pretty
rough
trying to do it
I mean so far I don't really like these
people
zero
you don't get to rush this
that's not very nice
I mean my thing is like that's kind of a
rough opener and then you don't know why
she did it
now I know there's leaks and rumors
about it but you obviously don't like
her right now as a character
I guess that wasn't the way to go guys
sorry about that
I was kind of wondered if that was gonna
happen that was that was pretty awesome
oh man it was too funny I think I can
jump down this one
it's still too high up you still gave me
the option to jump that first time that
was fun
oh my god duck and neck sorry thank you
you know right
and it already
not very nice man not nice way to kill
somebody
pendejo
[Applause]
the end well that was a rough ending
guys it was fun game it's been fun
playing it
yeah she's the immune girl without were
you Dina Jesus just gonna leave me here
God Dina your real disappointment of a
girlfriend I'll tell you why was Dina
withering and all of a sudden she just
let her probably think that touch melody
in the fields so Tommy's still alive
No I'm sobbing all right
Eitan what Oh see ya tinder in Colorado
and then then she goes back to Seattle's
was that biscuit maker yeah there you go
yeah I'm with you biscuit maker yeah I
forgot to go to Seattle
that's weird they didn't show that is
that gonna be a flashback of the dance
where she makes out with Deena I'm
confused
or is that just for the trailer and
we're just supposed to accept that we
saw it already
no pretty sure Joel's not alive anymore
buddy pretty sure his head's caved in
and he's not coming back I'm actually
surprised Tommy's alive this jambe joel
yeah that's actually a good idea one day
please I mean I know what the leaks I
kind of read a little bit about what the
leak said but I don't really know why
she hated Joel I mean the leaks are true
then I don't know but that's kind of why
I'm just playing through myself to see
what the story really is I mean so far
it's got me like you know I like it's a
revenge story like Joel gets killed okay
now where Ellie Ellie saw it go down now
she probably wants to avenge Joel right
so